a luz sobre nós
acordei sobressaltada consular da minha
morte do time forte legant e do porte e
foi enfrentar a minha sorte na janela vi
trovoadas e trovões via perda de ilusões
vividas por estrada sem ilusões e como
um raio forte exportador
vi a luz sobre nós a luz me iluminar
tirar do silêncio e dar voz fazendo
assinar a chinesa da correnteza foge mas
não não era boa aquela luz no arroba
minha janela tua era notícia da morte do
meu país
uma informação que não quis ouvir e
convidados e olhos arregalados e
sombrios vi o famoso gesto da decisão o
tal aperto de mão
inventado para transmitir respeito e
honestidade e agora utilizado para nos
vender com uma facilidade de assinaturas
venenosas empresas em 30 sangue são
injetadas pelas minhas veias tornando
boas intenções em coisas feias era com
agulhas braço quase nem deixavam espaço
para oxigênio fluir sufocava mas sem
sequer deixar cair viu lixo tube pretos
correndo pela correta do meu coisa óleo
venenoso marchando os meus símbolos e
enquanto porém transtornos procuramos
velhos quimbos perguntava onde estão os
heróis imortais os reais o que amavam
mais
o navarro guerreiro
esta luz sobre nós a luz com dizia que
não temos já não há marcas nem lutas
brasileiros kings homem de ideais como
roubo aos seus sonhos era ruim diz só
sabem que idéias a iniciativa passou
nada e não faltou da frente armada
falo de gente como tu e eu que devo
honrar essa terra amada
estamos na era dos pms acabou o tempo
dos no piauí agora são só dogs mesmo
homens meninos preocupados com marcas
marcando os invisíveis na luta pela
salvação da humanidade
não temos anarquistas ou bandidos do
velho oeste ocidental do nosso custo nos
versos como escolas tecnológicas e
lavagens que inspira a lógica e afastam
do nosso mestre hoje em dia - estrelas
que brilham como mandela gente que se
constrói sua novela cada saída comércio
mais forte motivador dessa triunfando
por mais dolorosa partida gente lugar
onde também que só pegou a moto mas não
não sejam conta cinderela não vos falo
telenovelas povos o patriotismo amor ao
próximo princípios paulo as coisas belas
mas o que eu posso eu vou confundindo
com o que eu devo do que o bebo home
embriagando por entre os medos e o que
eu temo aprisiona momentos e momentos
escondendo eras grãos de areia como
falando grandes esferas desencanto dos
tempos eu sou escrava moderna deixa
levar pelos ventos do correntes
ideológicas com blusas mórbidas duas
mamas psicológicas conclusão das
confecções segrego do meu irmão por
poucas e fracas ilusões e afastam das
paixões que realmente preenchem o meu
ser e de terem ter o fusca o meu próprio
divino buscando afete repentinos
riquezas contínuas e o que eu posso eu
vou confundindo com que eu devo e faço
menos do que escrevo e aceita opções de
camisas e até do relevo
porque não trabalhamos como ainda está
em tudo e nada covarde matemático
mostrarmos a grandeza da relatividade
o matemático velha idéia de que do galo
em grão a galinha enche o papo e do
facto porque nas partículas do massa
podem transformar se em grande
quantidade de energia e assim com graça
dizendo que os zumbis é o povo que se
unia tudo com beleza e mestria podemos
ser gente que devasta os pressupostos
temos o mesmo rosto lapidado pelos rios
da guerra
desculpe as culturas mudaram molduras
duas maduras forte para aguentar quantas
batalhas com 100
vamos amar mais essa nossa terra
vamos amar mais a nossa terra onde quem
manda é quem erra quem tenta ser para
depois te e não o inverso erra e eu por
não sentir parte deste tempo sem tempo
busco algo que me motiva ainda procura
essa tal da luz que apenas nas promessas
nos conduz e mesmo com o peso dos hinos
das glórias e quando sobre a minha mento
sinto muito tempo tenta um soldado sem
patente mas carregado de uma esperança
que viverá eternamente sinto convidar de
uma gente crente bastante eloqüente no
seu grito de liberdade
ovo do calor quente cujo frio com as nem
60 como que querendo pode e deve fazer
desta terra um lugar mais feliz
justificando então essa luz que não só
nas promessas nos conduzir
a cena
sei que vamos então à luz sobre nós essa
luz assustador s carmattos do ora pela
luz vencedora com as almas demos as mãos
e aprendamos o que é ser irmão e que o
islã pagos tran dozos não sejam mais
islã paxson doses sejam da semdi antes
no dias e que não mais estrondosos sejam
as alegrias muito obrigada
o grupo abrigado
muito obrigada muito obrigada eu ia
dizer que era um prazer estar aqui mas
assim é bom é que eu queria partilhar um
carinho com vocês o que tem sido a minha
alma meu percurso pela poesia desde a
escrita para do amado e agora para os
pouco antes só para dar uma breve
introdução e sufoco nordelo tipo isso
que eu acabei de fazer é é uma mutação
que a poesia sofreu também com a
influência da cultura hip hop e que
essencialmente é uma declamação mais
rápida do destino momento mais longos e
que a grande diferença é que a mensagem
transmitida amanhã mas direta muito mais
objetiva o que normalmente na poesia não
acontece e testando no mundo da poesia
fui aprendendo algumas lições
fantásticas como por exemplo só a poesia
a arte no geral é um milagre
vocês podem não concordar mas eu acho
que eh eh eh um milagre o fato de uma
pessoa que é um ser completamente
diferente de qualquer outro
compor uma obra que vai tocar a outra
pessoa e que vai transmitir o sentimento
a emoção então eu acho isso um milagre
pra mim não tem outra explicação
então que percebi então que eu tava
dentro de um milagre e que nós todos
temos essa capacidade e estamos estamos
a viver tempos estamos bem somos parte
destes grandes milagres da vida então só
quem só quem sai
só quem já percebe disso se aceita se
consegue sair da normalidade e as únicas
pessoas que conseguiram fazer coisas
fantásticas marcantes no mundo foram
pessoas que saíram da normalidade
então essa aceitação e como diz disseram
que alguns moradores saíram ouvir saber
ouvir essa essa voz interior esse
chamamento tubes vai conversar com ela
não vai pra direita para a esquerda
só de saber ouvir isso é muito
importante e mais importante ainda é
sabermos nos posicionar tomar a atitude
diante desse chamamento atitude correta
porque é para podermos é materializar o
poder do nosso potencial poder das
nossas ideias
devemos ter essa postura não o potencial
modo uma vez disseram na eles lá têm uma
responsabilidade pela tua vida
vamos chamar de irresponsável as plantas
entender que não era não era bem isso
era mais sentido nós às vezes pensaram
nos apercebemos do can can com do uso
dos rumos das nossas vidas não são os
nossos familiares nossos filhos os pais
o o parceiro do governo não é o nível de
escolaridade diz adriana que provas
disso
então quem quem define isso somos nós
mesmos a pessoa que está aqui dentro e
devemos ter essa postura tomar as rédeas
da situação e e e aprendi uma coisa
muito muito bonita que é assim nos dias
que nós transmitimos são mais fortes do
que as que nós cumprimos então nós cá
dentro podemos ser uma pessoa fantástica
com potencial maravilhoso fazer coisas
enormes mas como nós mandamos para o
mundo é completamente diferente
então é como se fossem duas 2 do flex da
mesma pessoa diz focados e quando
conseguimos o alinhá-los aí sim acontece
o milagre nós conseguimos expandir para
o mundo o nosso real potencial mental
nisso vica vi que a vida eu pensava que
eu só ia até aqui mas vi que a vida é
mais é muito mais aliás é sempre mais
quanto mais nós temos força receber mais
recebemos e quantas mais portas nós
achamos realmente mais entraves temos é
é como dizer que antes antes da poesia
eu era uma das 11 uma série de elementos
químicos e biológicos por aí e que agora
união central a panela e como sou eu não
sei se essa comida vai ficar boa não sei
se a conta vai dar resto 0 mas o que eu
sei que a experiência química começou a
reação como isso não tem preço
isso é isso que eu quero transmitir aqui
é e uma vez perguntaram na luz mas
conseguir mudar o mundo deles a final
eu consegui melhorar o meu mundo eo
mundo mais uma pessoa eu terei mudar do
mundo e nessa tentativa de mudança do
mundo disse vou sair da normalidade vou
fazer algo que não tem nada a ver com a
minha pessoa
vou aprender a fazer bbox e godoy útil
raul tube talks com uma aula de três
minutos sair dali uma profissional
e o resultado foi mais ou menos assim
notem nota dó da gota em gota de suor
escorregadio dançamos para o infinito e
volta
plantamos uma vida que brota deixa
penetrar a música que nos une tem comigo
vem em cerimônia ocorrida nos coligamos
aperta a fada qualquer dono espanha
alerta no hip hop jazz ao rock
estamos presos nota sul estamos presos
nessa falta tudo resta apenas unidos na
essência presos em cadência partilhando
da mesma veemência republicano amores a
mando das cordas do sol os dois maiores
na chamada número as pulsações em
sensações maiores e ficando quase
impunidade deixando penetrar a música
cana a zona tem comigo tem em cerimônia
escutei um som e percebi o que é amar
amar e dançará maria quebrar sobre a
pauta do coração reviver essa
musicalidade que quis alta é de clamar
as palavras da paixão
bush não interessa nem interessa quem
ama ou odeia a cor do sangue que corre
nas veias rapper o poeta cabe nessa
lisboeta o que interessa eu em
declarações à rede de penetra o que
interessa aqui neste instante até o som
do funk momentos eternizam se
sofrimentos amenizam os lamentos visão
lírica mágoas fazem mímica escreveu a
mulher estão doces de tentar ir tão
longe eu consigo tocar meu coração
chegou o teu sentimento tornas meu
milagres rítmicos manifestos a cada
batida de nós
orações e damos momentos tão bons a vida
política única não é monotônicas ensina
do tom para tom viver é bom faz barulho
o animal faz ruído mas quando é bom faz
sentido da vontade de apertar no player
abaixo daquilo que já foi vivido ea
música música só estude a música aquela
do escuro do ritmo nos faz sorrir e
chorar
a atriz lembra com saboroso e doloroso e
há mais música árbitro que nos faz dar
os braços a tarrachinha turma muitos
amassos seu kuduro que ninguém sabem por
quê mas todos amamos é o que a banda
população sendo a cabeça lula é normal
da ilha do bom lula seu heavy metal do
pessoal do preto que só pula aquela boa
vai no qual todos entramos
ouvimos uma seqüência sonora da novela é
mais que bela é a nossa tela novela
contada por batucadas na produção que
faz soar o destino é o nosso hino na
música unimo-nos com graça e lança sem
cabelos lisos nem rastas sem casta nem
pastas nem cargos - embargos e nós
podemos na rodando como seres
microscópicos pouco lógicos ligados
apenas pelo verso conversando entre as
galáxias e diariamento politizados por
essa matriz enfática prefeita que um dos
pontos mais ínfimos e distantes e
tornozelo num e amante no verso criamos
um universo
o buraco negro da simbiose dos átomos
que tão grande tornou-se no mais pequeno
coeso e sereno
o cruzeiro leva cruz na palavra seja ela
escrita ou falada jurado cantada a dor
quando dispensada eternizada
pois é a mais pura materialização humana
da irmã dado à disposição da sociedade
na música íntimas rio nem por isso deixa
planetária a música-tema zona tem comigo
pé em cerimônia
obrigada
além de cantar